La vache :
cinquante mille euros
le cours !
Je me demande
ce qu’ils pouvaient bien enseigner
à ce prix là
- mais en tout cas,
ça donne envie
d’être prof de philo !
Ah quand même :
si on était pas satisfait,
on pouvait avoir une remise.
Et quatre-vingt-dix-neuf pour cent,
c’est possible ?
Est-ce qu’on vous a déjà traité de « sophiste
» ?
Bon,
je ne vous le souhaite pas
- mais ça peut vous arriver un jour.
Maintenant,
est-ce que vous connaissez vraiment
le sens
du mot « sophiste » ?
Est-ce que vous savez
qu’à l’origine de cette insulte,
il y a une poignée d’hommes,
qui ont joué un rôle MAJEUR
dans la démocratie athénienne ?
Vous allez voir
que la réputation qu’on leur a fait
est en réalité
INJUSTE.
Il est temps
de RÉHABILITER
les sophistes.
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec Haristote,
et vous êtes
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai compris
qu’il fallait réhabiliter les sophistes
en lisant ce livre,
Les Grands Sophistes
dans l'Athènes de Périclès,
de Jacqueline De Romilly.
Comme je le fais systématiquement
depuis les quelques vidéos précédentes,
je vous permets de télécharger
mes notes de lecture,
en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou sur celui qui est dans la description,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Alors,
Jacqueline De Romilly,
c’était une essayiste française,
une spécialiste,
reconnue dans le monde entier,
de la civilisation
et de la langue de la Grèce antique.
Dans Les Grands Sophistes
dans l'Athènes de Périclès,
elle résout une énigme :
les hommes de l’Antiquité grecque
qu’on appelle « les sophistes »,
qui étaient des voyageurs
venus de toute la Grèce,
ces hommes
sont aujourd’hui peu connus,
alors qu’ils étaient très influents
dans l’Athènes rayonnante
du siècle dit « de Périclès »
- le cinquième siècle
avant Jésus-Christ.
Même les plus grands sophistes
sont aujourd’hui peu connus :
Protagoras,
Gorgias,
Hippias,
Prodicos,
ou encore Thrasymaque -
ces noms
ne vous disent probablement
pas grand chose
parce que la notoriété de ces hommes
a été affaiblie,
mais aussi ternie
dans leur passage à la postérité.
Comment est-ce possible ?
C’est bien simple :
la réalité historique
et l’histoire des idées
ont été déformées.
Les sophistes méritent donc
d’être réhabilités
- au moins pour cinq raisons.
Alors,
comme à mon habitude
lorsque je m’interroge sur un mot,
je vais regarder l’étymologie
sur le Wiktionnaire :
Ah bah non tiens,
« sophiste »,
ça ne veut pas dire escroc !
En fait,
ça vient tout simplement,
comme le mot « philosophie »,
du grec sophia,
qui veut dire la sagesse,
ou le savoir.
Bah oui,
les sophistes étaient en fait,
au sens large,
des professeurs
- c’est-à-dire des professionnels du savoir.
Thrasymaque,
un des plus renommés d’entre eux,
a d’ailleurs fait inscrire
sur son tombeau :
« Ma patrie était Chalcédoine
- Chalcédoine c’est une cité grecque
située dans l’actuelle Turquie -
et ma profession le savoir ».
Voilà,
donc un sophiste,
c’était un prof.
On peut même considérer,
d’après Jacqueline De Romilly,
que tous les profs
sont les héritiers des sophistes,
puisqu’ils ont été les premiers,
dans la civilisation occidentale,
à se professionnaliser
dans la transmission du savoir.
Or,
qui dit profession,
dit rémunération
- les sophistes étaient donc payés
pour leurs leçons.
Et certains très grassement,
même.
Le tarif de cinquante mille euros
que j’évoque en accroche,
c’est le prix d’une leçon avec Protagoras,
un des plus grands sophistes,
qui apparaît dans certains dialogues de Platon.
Petite précision :
c’est moi qui ait fait la conversion
des drachmes
en euros de deux-mille dix-huit
- déjà c’est très approximatif,
et puis je ne vais pas vous bassiner
avec mes hypothèses de calcul,
je les mets dans la description de la vidéo,
et si vous voyez une erreur,
surtout dites-le moi
dans les commentaires.
Alors,
cinquante mille euros la leçon de Protagoras,
ça semble incroyable,
impossible
- comment l’expliquer ?
Le premier élément à prendre en compte,
c’est que comme les sophistes étaient critiqués
déjà à leur époque
- en partie parce que leurs leçons
étaient onéreuses
d’ailleurs -
eh bien
le montant a probablement été
grossièrement surévalué
par les détracteurs des sophistes
- donc a priori
c’est beaucoup moins,
MAIS ça reste beaucoup.
Alors,
comment l’expliquer ?
Eh bien c’est simple :
Protagoras était une star ;
les sophistes les plus renommés
étaient des stars,
et ils étaient les idoles
de beaucoup de jeunes gens.
Et ça coûte combien
quelques heures avec une star ?
Alors j’ai fait quelques recherches :
en France,
la conférence d’un intellectuel de premier
plan
peut coûter jusqu’à dix mille euros
- et puis je sais aussi
de source personnelle
que si vous le voulez à un dîner privé
- c’est généralement
pour des dîners d’affaires -
eh bien c’est environ
le même montant.
On est pas très loin des cinquante mille
de Protagoras.
Et puis si on s’intéresse
aux conférences des anciens chefs d’État
mondialement connus,
ça va bien au-delà :
François Hollande,
c’est au moins cent mille euros ;
Barack Obama,
qui est très demandé,
c’est quatre-cent mille ;
enfin,
Bill Clinton,
le champion toutes catégories confondues,
demande parfois
plus de six-cent mille euros
pour un discours
- Protagoras,
c’est un petit joueur à côté.
Et puis,
si les discours convenus
ce n’est pas trop votre truc,
vous préférez peut-être
un concert privé de Madonna ?
C’est un million d’euros,
pour quelques heures.
Donc tout compte fait,
la rémunération des sophistes stars
n’est pas si étonnante que ça.
Par ailleurs,
j’ai fait le même calcul
pour des sophistes moins renommés,
et je suis arrivé à des tarifs
qui correspondent
à ceux des cours particuliers modernes
- donc rien de scandaleux.
C’est sûr que Platon,
qui dénonce le business des sophistes,
pouvait enseigner gratuitement
et passer son temps
dans le ciel des idées,
lui qui était l’héritier
d’une des plus illustres familles d’Athènes.
Mais surtout,
les sophistes n’escroquaient pas leurs élèves
pour remplir leur frigo :
d’après Jacqueline De Romilly,
ils étaient de très bons pédagogues,
et ils transmettaient des compétences
de grande valeur.
Socrate a des mots très durs contre les sophistes
:
il les trouve arrogants,
et puis il dénonce leur esprit mercantile
- selon lui,
n’importe quel citoyen
pourrait bien apprendre la même chose
aux jeunes gens
qui suivent les cours des sophistes.
Je ne vais pas évoquer l’opposition des
théories,
mais Socrate,
à lire Platon,
est L'ADVERSAIRE des sophistes.
MAIS SI on compare leurs méthodes intellectuelles,
eh bien elles sont assez proches,
en réalité.
La dialectique de Socrate,
c’est-à-dire la manière qu’il a,
dans les dialogues,
d’opposer les positions,
et ça en s’intéressant sincèrement
à la thèse adverse,
eh bien cette méthode
repose sur le même principe
que la démarche des sophistes,
qui se mettent à la place de l’adversaire
pour s’entraîner à défendre sa thèse
- on retrouve par exemple cette démarche
dans la technique de Protagoras dite
des « discours doubles »,
qui consiste à soutenir successivement
deux points de vue opposés.
Donc fondamentalement,
les deux méthodes,
celle de Socrate
et celle des sophistes,
reposent sur la même idée :
la recherche de la vérité
demande de pratiquer une empathie
à l’égard des personnes
qui ne sont pas d’accord avec nous
- après,
Socrate et les sophistes
n’arrivent pas aux mêmes conclusions
- les sophistes sont
beaucoup plus sceptiques -
mais d’après Jacqueline De Romilly,
la proximité de leurs démarches intellectuelles
laisse soupçonner
une certaine influence des sophistes
sur Socrate.
De là à imaginer que Socrate
ait été un de leurs élèves,
c’est peut-être un peu exagéré :
Platon dit certes dans le Ménon
que Socrate a écouté
une leçon de Prodicos
- mais c’était une seule leçon,
et une leçon bon marché.
Pour autant,
Socrate était en relation constante
avec les sophistes,
et il est fort probable
qu’il leur doive
son agilité intellectuelle méthodique.
D’ailleurs,
certains auteurs,
comme Aristophane,
se sont moqués de Socrate
en le qualifiant de sophiste !
Jacqueline De Romilly fait alors l’hypothèse
que c’est en raison de cette probable filiation,
entre les sophistes
et Socrate,
et de la confusion qui en découle,
que Platon fait réfuter les sophistes
par Socrate
dans ses dialogues.
Bref,
la chose à retenir,
c’est qu’il y a probablement
un peu
- au moins un peu -
des sophistes
chez Socrate.
Et leur influence est plus éclatante
chez d’autres grands auteurs :
Euripide,
le grand poète tragique,
a par exemple été l’élève
de Protagoras
et de Prodicos
(qui était moins cher) ;
Autre exemple :
Thucydide,
le premier historien rationnel,
aurait lui été l’élève
de Gorgias,
de Prodicos,
et d'Antiphon
Jacqueline De Romilly conclut plus généralement
de ses recherches :
« Tous les écrivains du temps
ont été leurs disciples
ou ont appris d’eux quelque chose,
les ont imités
ou bien discutés.
»
Et il y a une raison toute simple à ça :
ils étaient bons.
Les sophistes étaient des professeurs,
mais ils n’étaient pas que ça.
Il faut se méfier des catégories :
ce n’est pas parce qu’on est un professeur,
c’est-à-dire un passeur de savoir,
qu’on ne peut pas être aussi
un PRODUCTEUR de savoir.
Au contraire même,
être un passeur de savoir
est probablement une position privilégiée,
et peut-être même nécessaire,
pour devenir un PRODUCTEUR de savoir
- c’est d’ailleurs le cas aujourd’hui,
de beaucoup de profs d’université,
du lycée
ou du collège.
Bref,
je reviens aux sophistes :
ils n’étaient pas seulement des professeurs
réputés,
ils étaient aussi
d’authentiques penseurs.
On les réduit souvent à des maîtres de
rhétoriques,
mais ils étaient en même temps
des philosophes,
de vrais philosophes
avec des doctrines
qui avaient une incidence dans la réalité.
En fait,
c’est même à cette dimension de leur activité
qu’ils doivent leur célébrité,
parce qu’ils ont diffusé
des idées assez controversées
(pour l’époque).
Pour faire simple,
ce qui choquait dans leurs théories,
ce qui était perçu comme une menace
pour l’ordre social,
c’était leur RELATIVISME radical.
Vous connaissez peut-être
la célèbre formule de Protagoras :
« L’homme est la mesure
de toutes choses.
»
Eh bien cette formule
était un peu le mot d’ordre des sophistes.
Or,
les idées qui en découlent
sont puissantes :
rien ne peut être connu en soi-même,
tout est relatif,
donc la vérité n’existe pas
- et du coup,
la seule chose qui compte,
c’est que l’interlocuteur
croit que c’est vrai -
le relativisme des sophistes
menaçait aussi la justice :
les lois n’ont pas de valeur dans l’absolu,
ce sont juste des règles
créées par les hommes ;
et enfin la religion :
les dieux eux aussi
sont des inventions humaines.
Alors,
ces idées attaquaient violemment
les croyances de l’homme du commun,
donc elles semblaient dangereuses
- d’ailleurs les sophistes se sont pris
pas mal de procès,
comme Socrate -
MAIS d’un autre côté,
le relativisme des sophistes
a également libéré les esprits,
et il leur a donné une perspective fructueuse
pour produire du savoir.
La dimension la plus importante
de cette perspective,
c’est la promotion du doute :
le scepticisme des sophistes
a donné un élan décisif
à l’idée selon laquelle
le savoir progresse de manière négative,
en invalidant des hypothèses,
c’est-à-dire par essai et erreur successifs.
Or,
cette idée qui nous est familière
grâce à Descartes,
et plus récemment Karl Popper,
elle est au fondement de la science moderne.
Du coup,
Jacqueline De Romilly estime
que la doctrine des sophistes
peut être considérée
comme une des racines de la science.
De manière moins surprenante,
leur perspective intellectuelle
a également fait progresser l’analyse du
langage
et les techniques de la parole.
Comme ils étaient passionnés par le débat,
et qu’ils enseignaient l’art de les gagner,
ils ont donné une forte impulsion
à la rhétorique,
considérée comme une discipline.
Enfin,
le relativisme des sophistes
a plus généralement
nourri les sciences humaines :
leur méthode dialectique
a fait progresser des disciplines
dans lesquelles
il faut confronter différentes positions,
comme le droit,
ou la stratégie militaire ;
leur intérêt pour la politique
et les constitutions
a alimenté la science politique ;
leur obsession de l’argument de vraisemblance,
c’est-à-dire les réactions communes des
hommes
aux idées qui leur sont présentées,
cette obsession
a augmenté la valeur
des observations d'ordre psychologique.
Et puis,
il faut rappeler que le sophiste
se définit comme quelqu’un
qui se consacre au savoir :
or,
les sophistes historiques ne se sont pas cantonnés
à la rhétorique et à la philosophie,
ils ont aussi touché à l’histoire,
au droit,
aux mathématiques,
à la médecine
- en fait,
ils avaient pour ambition,
une ambition un peu délirante,
mais une belle ambition,
de maîtriser le savoir
dans sa totalité.
Si on écoute un détracteur des sophistes
:
ils défendaient le mensonge,
l’inégalité,
le vol,
l’injustice,
l’athéisme,
le désordre
- bref,
leur relativisme détruisait tout
sur leur passage.
Puisque « l’homme est la mesure
de toutes choses »,
rien n’a de valeur dans l’absolu,
rien n’est interdit,
et tout fout le camp.
C’est un peu un Mai 68
de l’Athènes de Périclès
- non, je plaisante,
mais il y a de ça.
Bon eh bien,
ce prétendu immoralisme des sophistes,
c’est une caricature.
Ils n’ont pas supprimé toute morale,
ils ont en réalité proposé
une AUTRE morale,
une morale pragmatique.
Qu’est-ce qui est important
pour les sophistes ?
Qu’est-ce qui fonde
les valeurs
en lesquelles ils croient ?
Quel est le critère qui nous dit
ce qu’il faut préférer,
et ce qu’il faut refuser ?
Ce critère,
c’est l’utilité.
Les sophistes ont substitué l’utilité
à la vérité.
Dans cette perspective,
une opinion est supérieure à une autre
si elle se traduit dans la réalité
par des bénéfices supérieurs,
ou par des inconvénients moindres
que l’autre opinion.
L’homme qui incarne cette sagesse,
c’est le médecin :
dans l’exercice de sa profession,
le médecin évalue ses idées
en fonction de l’effet concret
qu’elles sont susceptibles de produire
chez le malade.
Pour les sophistes,
l’homme a intérêt à s’inspirer du médecin
:
il doit privilégier les idées
qui le mettent,
lui mais aussi autrui,
dans de meilleures dispositions.
Or,
cette morale se transpose facilement
à l’échelle de la cité :
toute idée ou solution
qui contribue davantage à l’intérêt commun
a plus de valeur
qu’une autre.
Et c’est comme ça
que les sophistes légitiment
la justice,
les institutions politiques,
et même les dieux,
dans la mesure où
ils créent du lien entre les hommes.
Alors qu’on fait d’eux
les apôtres du chaos,
les sophistes valorisaient en réalité
la bonne entente entre les citoyens
et la paix intérieure.
Ils considéraient même
que c’est la vie collective
qui fera pénétrer en l’individu
les vertus qui lui sont favorables
- en d’autres termes,
il faut protéger la vie sociale
parce que la société
est le milieu particulier
qui rend l’homme
VERTUEUX.
On est loin de l’apologie de la guerre civile
!
Le relativisme des sophistes
débouche donc sur une morale
- une morale certes pragmatique,
mais une morale quand même,
une morale bien réelle,
si réelle
que les sophistes passaient même
pour des maîtres de morale.
Les sophistes,
des maîtres de morale ?
Comment c’est possible ?
C’est là
la principale raison
de les réhabiliter.
À ce stade,
vous l’avez compris :
c’est une caricature des sophistes
que l’on nous sert.
Platon,
dont la fortune familiale le protège
des intérêts bassement matériels,
nous les présente
par la bouche de Socrate
comme des escrocs ;
sur le plan du savoir,
on les réduit
à des maîtres de rhétorique
sans scrupules ;
sur le plan moral,
enfin,
leur détracteurs dénoncent leur immoralisme
qui mettrait l’ordre même de la société
en péril.
Il y a bien sûr des choses vraies
dans cette critique :
les sophistes les plus réputés
donnaient des leçons
horriblement chères
à la jeunesse dorée athénienne ;
certains d’entre eux
se consacraient entièrement
au succès oratoire,
au mépris total de toute vérité ;
enfin,
d’autres méritaient effectivement
l’accusation d’immoralisme
qui a rejailli sur tous les sophistes.
MAIS enfin,
c’est comme dans tout mouvement :
il y a du bon,
et du mauvais ;
il y a des excès
en tous genres ;
il y a des dissensions.
Parce qu'évidemment,
les sophistes n’étaient pas tous
d’accord entre eux
- non seulement politiquement,
mais plus généralement
sur leur vision du monde,
et même plus spécifiquement
sur le contenu de leur enseignement.
Alors maintenant,
comment expliquer la caricature
dont ils sont victimes ?
Jacqueline De Romilly
met en évidence cinq causes :
la première,
c’est le contexte politique :
la vie politique athénienne a baissé en
intensité
après le cinquième siècle,
et leur enseignement
est donc devenu moins nécessaire ;
la seconde,
c’est le probable court-termisme des sophistes
:
trop occupés par le quotidien,
ils auraient négligé leur œuvre
et sa transmission,
c’est-à-dire qu’ils n’ont pas cherché
à maîtriser un tant soit peu
leur postérité ;
la troisième,
c’est leur esprit mercantile :
poussés par l’appât du gain,
ils se seraient trop spécialisés,
pour finir comme maîtres de rhétorique ;
la quatrième,
c’est leur ambition :
certains sophistes,
parmi les plus renommés,
ont pris la grosse tête,
au point qu’ils véhiculaient l’image
de professeurs élitistes
préoccupés uniquement de leur business,
qui n’en avaient donc rien à faire
de la vérité
et de la morale.
enfin,
la cinquième et dernière cause,
probablement la plus importante,
c’est que ce sont les disciples
de la première génération de sophistes
- ceux que Jacqueline De Romilly
appelle « les Grands Sophistes » -
ce sont leurs disciples
qui auraient vraiment forcé le trait
et suscité la controverse.
MAIS les Grands Sophistes,
ces premiers professionnels du savoir
qui venaient de toute la Grèce,
eux ne méritent pas la réputation
qu’on leur a fait.
Parce que sans eux,
les autres
- les Socrate,
Platon,
Périclès,
Thucidyde,
Euripide,
Aristophane -
sans les sophistes,
les grands ne seraient pas devenus
ce qu’ils sont.
Sans eux,
nous ne serions pas nous-mêmes
ce que nous sommes,
selon Jacqueline de Romilly,
parce que tout l’humanisme occidental,
c’est-à-dire l’idée
que l’homme devient meilleur
grâce à un certain rapport au savoir,
cette idée décisive,
c’est probablement aux sophistes
que nous la devons.
Merci d’avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu’au
bout !
Alors,
moi je ne vous demande pas
cinquante mille euros ;
je vous demande seulement,
si la vidéo vous a plu,
de lui donner un pouce bleu,
et puis de vous abonner à la chaîne
si vous aimez la vulgarisation
de la pensée ;
et enfin peut-être
de laisser un petit commentaire.
Je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez télécharger
mes notes de lectures,
en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou sur celui qui est dans la description,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Si vous voulez lire
ma synthèse écrite détaillée
de l'essai de Jacqueline de Romilly
qui est sur le blog,
ou si vous souhaitez le lire directement,
tous les liens sont dans la description.
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec mon fidèle Haristote
- que je ne suis pas mécontent
de ne pas avoir baptisé Platon -
et sous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Vous n’avez pas besoin
de payer cinquante mille euros
pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée,
SANS vous prendre la tête.